Welcome to our Channel today we're
diving into the best vegetable seeds to
start indoors in February especially if
you're in a cold climate like me
starting seeds indoors is the perfect
way to get a jump start on the growing
season even if winter is still holding
on tight let's gather our supplies and
get
started first up we have the Beloved
tomato this versatile fruit often
mistaken for a vegetable is a staple in
gardens around the world whether you're
a seasoned Gardener or a beginner
growing tomatoes can be a rewarding
experience tomatoes need a long growing
season so starting them indoors in
February is ideal this gives them a head
start before the outdoor growing season
begins Begin by filling seed trays with
a high quality seed starting mix use a
seed starting mix moisten it and plant
seeds about a/4 inch deep it's important
to ensure the mix is evenly moist but
not water logged this creates the
perfect environment for seeds to
germinate place your seed trays in a
bright south facing window or use grow
lights tomatoes need plenty of light to
grow strong and healthy if natural light
is insufficient grow lights can provide
the necessary illumination keep the soil
consistently moist but not soggy
overwatering can lead to root rot while
underwatering can cause the seedlings to
dry out
a gentle misting or careful watering can
help maintain the right moisture level
once your tomato seedlings Sprout ensure
they get at least 6 hours of sunlight
per day this is crucial for their
development if using grow lights keep
them on for 12 16 hours a day to mimic
natural sunlight with a little love and
attention your tomato seedlings will
Thrive indoors and be ready to
transplant Outdoors once the danger of
Frost has passed gradually acclimate
them to outdoor conditions by placing
them outside for a few hours each day
increasing the time over a
[Music]
week next up let's talk about Peppers
these vibrant and versatile plants can
add a burst of flavor and color to any
dish whether you're a fan of the sweet
and Mild or the fiery and hot there's a
pepper variety for everyone just like
tomatoes peppers thrive in warm weather
and need a long growing season they are
sun-loving plants that require plenty of
light and warmth to grow strong and
healthy starting your pepper seeds
indoors can give them a head start
especially in regions with shorter
growing Seasons choose from sweet bell
peppers to spicy jalapenos bell peppers
are great for salads and stir fries
while jalapenos can add a kick to your
Salsas and sauces there are also many
other varieties like Habaneros cayenne
and banana peppers each with its unique
flavor and heat level plant your pepper
seeds in a high quality seed starting
mix about a/4 in deep make sure the soil
is moist but not water logged using a
seed tray with a clear cover can help
maintain humidity and warmth which are
crucial for germination Peppers thrive
in warmth so maintain a temperature of
around 70 to 80° f using a heat mat can
help keep the soil at the right
temperature especially in cooler
climates consistent warmth will
encourage faster germination and
stronger seedling
once your pepper seedlings emerge
provide them with ample sunlight or grow
lights they need at least 14 16 hours of
light each day to grow well if natural
sunlight is limited using grow lights
can ensure they get the necessary light
for
photosynthesis to encourage strong stems
gently brush your hand over the
seedlings a few times each day this
mimics the natural movement of wind and
helps the plants develop sturdier stems
preparing them for the outdoor your
environment regularly check the moisture
level of the soil and water as needed to
keep it consistently damp but not
soggy now let's move on to eggplants
those beautiful glossy vegetables that
add A Touch of Elegance to any Garden
eggplants need a long growing season and
warmth so starting them indoors in
February is key use a seed starting mix
moisten it and plant seeds about 1/4 in
deep maintain a consistent temperature
of around 75° F with a heating mat once
your eggplant seedlings emerge ensure
they get plenty of bright indirect
sunlight let's turn our attention to
broccoli a cool weather crop that
thrives in the crisp days of spring and
fall broccoli is not only nutritious but
also versatile in the kitchen making it
a favorite among gardeners and chefs
alike starting broccoli indoors in
February gives it a head start this
early start is crucial because broccoli
needs a long growing season to develop
its full flavor and nutritional profile
and ensures it has ample time to mature
before the summer heat sets in the heat
can cause broccoli to bolt or flour
prematurely which affects its taste and
texture use a highquality seed starting
mix moisten it and make sure it is well
draining to prevent root rot sew seeds
about a/ in deep planting them at the
right depth ensures they have the best
chance to germinate and grow strong
broccoli seedlings prefer cooler
temperatures which helps them develop
sturdy stems and healthy leaves around
60 to 65° F maintaining this temperature
range is key to preventing stress and
promoting steady growth keep the soil
consistently moist but not water logged
overwatering can lead to fungal diseases
so it's important to strike the right
balance regularly check your seedlings
for any signs of pest or diseases and
provide adequate light to ensure they
grow strong and healthy with the right
care your broccoli plants will be ready
to transplant Outdoors when the weather
warms
up now let's move on to cauliflower
another cool weather crop that's a
relative of broccoli starting
cauliflower indoors in February gives it
a head start and ensures it has ample
time to mature before the heat of Summer
arrives use a highquality seed starting
mix moisten it and sew seeds about a/ in
deep cauliflower seedlings thrive in
cooler temperatures around 60 to 65° F
keep the soil consistently moist but not
water
logged now let's talk about lettuce a
fast growing and rewarding crop that's
perfect for starting indoors starting
lettuce indoors in February ensures you
have a steady supply of fresh greens
through throughout the spring and into
the summer use a highquality seed
starting mix moisten it and sew seeds
about 1/4 in deep lettuce seedlings
prefer cooler temperatures ideally
between 60 and 70° F they thrive in
bright in direct
light let's move on to spinach a
nutrient packed power house that's as
delicious as it is good for you starting
spinach indoors in February ensures you
have a steady supply of fresh tender
spinach leaves use a highquality seed
starting mix moisten it and sew seeds
about a half in deep spinach seedlings
prefer cooler temperatures ideally
between 60 and 70° F they thrive in
bright indirect
light last but certainly not least let's
talk about kale a Hardy and versatile
green that's as nutritious as it is
delicious starting kale indor in
February ensures you have a steady
supply of fresh nutritious kale use a
highquality seed starting mix moisten it
and sew seeds about a half in deep kale
seedlings prefer cooler temperatures
ideally between 60 and 70° F they thrive
in bright indirect
light thanks for watching we hope you
found this guide to starting vegetable
seeds indoors in February helpful
starting your seeds indoors gives your
plant a head start ensuring a Bountiful
Harvest later in the season happy
planting don't forget to like subscribe
and hit the Bell icon for more gardening
tips and tricks happy planting